I have to formally and humbly apologize
to Mr Beast so here's the situation
[Music]
all right let's jump in I have a bunch
of topics here
um
I gotta start with an apology
I have to formally and humbly apologize
to Mr Beast so here's the situation
we've talked about it a little bit
before uh back when we did Camp MFM we
invited Mr Beast
um and I should say invited meaning we
invited ourselves to his house uh
basically in order to do it we were like
oh yeah we're gonna do this he's like
yeah that'd be cool but you know
schedule's a little crazy I'm interested
but you know not in LA because I'm in
North Carolina we're like oh coincidence
what town do you live in that's where
we're doing it and so we went out there
had a good time one of the things that
happened was I made them we were touring
Duke's uh campus and we're on on their
basketball court and I made him a bet
that I could I could make a half court
shot before he did for ten thousand
dollars very stupid bet he he stood the
game nothing and used to gain everything
so he could get ten thousand dollars
also oh I didn't know that you had to
pay him ten thousand dollars all right
yeah yeah whoever made it first
um so so put 10 grand up he's like I had
learned this over the course of a few
days he's like me he's a he's a bit of a
degenerate Gambler like uh I think his
company they have like a separate bank
account or it's like yeah Beast you
could gamble this but don't don't touch
the main stuff uh and that's all money
he already one from gambling so they're
like look that's your house money to
play with petty cash pedicure cash
um I think although I think the petty
cash was like seven figures if I was
getting them correct so anyways bet them
this amount hit the shot glorious moment
and then
um it's like we're so busy you know we
just go back to doing the camp and it's
like yeah cool uh you know I'll pay you
um and I was like great yo baby that's
what he does and so he didn't right away
and so I was like and everybody all the
other people on the trip are like yo
that was awesome awesome moment
um did he pay you and I had to just be
like no no not yet but he's good for it
for sure right he's good for it and um
and so that became the running joke was
like no no he didn't pay yet but but he
will and um
and I brought it up on the podcast
because I I talked about this on the on
our end of your Awards as like a
highlight moment was saying dude I bet
you I can make the shot in half court of
Cameron Indoor Stadium this hallowed you
know college basketball stadium and just
having the balls to make that bet and
then having the the the luck of hitting
it
um was a high moment and I said the low
moment was
following up like three weeks later and
be like hey man hey hey
um you got that but yeah no no rush but
you got that money yeah
this wasn't a fake bet this was a real
bet bro like you know first set it in a
joking way like ah [__] better pay my
money then three weeks later like hey
did you pay and so then I was like oh
man low moment was being the like having
to follow up and being like yeah
basically begging for the cash he was
cool the whole time he was just like oh
yeah my bad I'll have my assistant pay
and I was like yeah no problem uh cool
and so that I said that joke on the
podcast and then people have been
referencing it like uh like later like
people will I don't know why listeners
reference it they tweet about it every
once in a while and so I guess he saw
this tweet recently and this is now like
many months it's like six six months
later yeah he was like
uh somebody was somebody tweeted out
this whole story this whole thread they
go
you know I I realize why the Mr Beast
not paying you stories like didn't sit
right with me and it's because you Sean
also stood me up you said you wanted to
invest in my thing and that we should
talk and then I followed up three times
over email asking me like hey you said
you wanted to invest and like let's talk
let's talk and you haven't replied to
three of my emails and like you're
ghosting me just like he goes to do
um not cool and if you want to you know
make things right you should take that
call and you should invest in my company
and so he kind of put this out there as
a bit of a ballsy tweet thread and um Mr
B saw it and he DM me he's like what are
you talking about like I paid you like a
while back what do you mean
and I was like what oh and I went oh
dude
so I had given him a Bitcoin like a
fresh Bitcoin wallet because he's like
I'll pay you a Bitcoin I was like all
right no problem
and I'd give him a Bitcoin wallet and uh
I never checked this thing because like
you know who checks it's like a random
Bitcoin wallet you created he paid me
back in November and so for months I've
been like telling this joke about the
like hey uh
you know just I I know you probably
meant to do it but you didn't do it yet
just uh when you get a chance no no rush
when you get a chance just you think
he's pissed at you
no I don't think I don't think he was a
[__] uh in the same way that I didn't
actually give a [__] I just thought it
was funny like uh like um the other
thing we learned at that camp with from
that guy minhaj the the comedian he goes
comedy is all about low status and I
remember that and I took that I was like
oh my comedy is usually trying to be
cocky funny like somebody says something
and I say how dude you know like you
were like you don't know about pop
culture and I was like bro I am pop
culture right like it's more cocky but
actually what I learned from Hudson was
that low status is actually a more a
funnier more endearing way to to you
know sort of win people over so telling
this story about like yeah that I had to
follow up and it turned from this cool
moment to this incredibly lame moment
that was a loss it's a it's trying to do
a low status comedy thing
but then I realized I had been wrong the
whole time he paid me in November so so
uh yeah whoops damn dude that's a nice
that's a pretty big mess up you're just
disparaging this guy yeah I was
slandering the dude left and right just
saying uh you know at least I pay my
debts uh right like you know I was I was
joking around like that but uh but
incorrect he paid all right
we have an end happy ending
yeah I was shocked that you were saying
that on air by the way
I chose yeah that he didn't pay I was
like I'm this is gonna make me play to
him I didn't just say it rarely people
asked did he pay and then I'm like oh
what am I gonna say yes no if I didn't
think he paid I was gonna say no I
wasn't just like proactively being like
by the way
call out you know that that's not how it
was I appreciate you know who I uh
sometimes you know it's just the people
listening it's just Sean and I basically
you know Zoom right now we're on a
Riverside so just us talking and it's
very easy to forget that there's other
people who will hear this I found myself
saying stuff yeah you get real
comfortable you get very comfortable and
I admire Joe Rogan I don't listen to
Tony Joe Rogan but I do watch some of
his clips and he does a really good job
of he rarely disrespects people
he'll say like oh they just have a
difference of opinion it's all good or
he'll say someone will bring up hey did
you hear how this person was talking
trash and he'll just say oh you know
that's funny that's funny he does a
really good job of not picking fights
and uh I saw on your thing on your list
you have this kind of fight that started
and it looks like I started it and I
don't want it to come off that way but
basically
um on this pod I tried never to like
pick fights or if I do pick a fight it's
like I'm actually gonna go to battle
with this and you have this uh what's
the guy's name Steven Bartlett thing on
there yeah yeah I want to bring that up
yeah by the way I I actually want to say
this uh you're right that when it's me
and you just talking like this and
there's nobody else here
it's really easy to get comfortable you
forget oh cool 150 000 people are
listening right if I was in front of an
audience if I could see 150 000 people
there's no way I would feel as
comfortable and as loose making jokes or
or saying something or like I'll do this
often it's got me in a lot of trouble
actually yeah you say so it's bad
and
I decided as long as I'll as long as I'm
saying something that I actually think
um
I'm gonna carry on in that way because
uh I don't usually think negative things
about people well the way that I do it
nowadays and the Pod actually taught me
this which was if I'm gonna talk
negatively about someone behind their
back I better be ready to say to their
face and so I work really hard to only
say things privately that I'm okay
saying to that person or even publicly
sometimes uh and that's the takeaway I
think it was um have you heard the story
of like a blink and basically he like
talked trash about some guy and they're
like I challenge you to a duel and he's
like
[__] I don't want to go to a duel and so
he's like dude I'm sorry I'm afraid I
don't want to fight you and then he's
like that's it I've never talked trash
about people and I remember reading that
I'm like that's a good sign and talking
trash is easy I do it every once in a
while just because I'm human
but if you're gonna do it you gotta we
gotta be able to say it to their face
and so that's kind of my role that I try
to live by but it's very hard to follow
but all right you want to talk about the
Bartlett thing yeah yeah okay so um you
Tee It Up because I think you you
tweeted it out so what's on your mind
there's well nothing I was just curious
but basically there's a guy named
Stephen Bartlett he's got a pod that's
quite good uh it's mostly a YouTube
thing I think but uh pretty good he's
interviews interesting people background
is he had a company called social chain
which there's a long story about it that
we've talked about before where he
basically owned among other things a
bunch of Twitter handles and he could
help make a product popular or a TV show
Popular by sharing it amongst all the
Twitter handles whatever it's an agency
it was relatively successful it was
definitely successful he was like kind
of a prodigy it uh ends up getting
Acquired and the company that acquired
it did like some type of reverse merger
it goes public at its peak hundreds of
millions of dollars an article came out
on Thursday and by the way this guy
Stephen he worked for Sean as an intern
when he was 21 years old and we've said
fun stories about that uh an article
came out that said this thing was sold
for 8 million and I shared I go whoa
this thing was only sold for 8 million I
thought this was like a publicly traded
company for hundreds of millions I'm a
little confused what's the story here
and people got pissed not at me they got
pissed at him saying
um this guy's saying he's built up a 300
million dollar company and they listed
tons of evidence saying otherwise and I
didn't actually look in the evidence I
don't know the truth but people were
really angry at that
and uh it was it was it was pretty wild
to see yeah I think the
so you uh I think you framed it well
there's basically
two things going on here one as somebody
gets really famous the Target on their
back gets bigger and so he's become more
and more famous he uh has a very big
kind of social media presence I think
he's got like a million followers on
Instagram or Twitter or something like
that
um LinkedIn he's big as well he's on the
Shark Tank of England yeah he's on
Dragon's Den which is like Shark Tank in
um in Europe
so he's like well known there he uh
wrote a book he you know he's like doing
things he goes on he has this podcast he
goes on these like tours basically where
he like speaks he's a guy I call him the
black garyvee uh he's like very much
like garyvee in my opinion and in the
same way that some people not carry V
I'm like bro you didn't build your you
know you didn't build a business that
was your dad's business that you were
just the marketing guy for and he's like
well actually like the business was
really small and then I started Wine
Library TV and it grew much bigger you
know there's people who come out and say
oh you're not as you represent yourself
and so when you see this headline that
oh his agency sold for seven million
dollars you're like bro what seven
million like what why are you
representing yourself as much bigger
than you are
and um
the explanation I think is kind of
simple so here's the explanation his
agency was called social chain
when they got acquired they renamed the
larger company which didn't have as much
of a public facing brand social chain
group and so social chain group was a
bigger business that did many things had
many agencies underneath
um had some you know had some other
things that there's an e-commerce
there's a big e-commerce business that
was with it they sold there like a
mattress company basically and most of
the revenue like comes came from the
e-commerce side and a smaller slice of
the revenue came from the agency size
and even a smaller size came from his
specific agency called social chain I
think when he sold when social chain got
acquired or whatever by the larger group
I think they were at roughly 9 million a
year in Revenue something like that and
that was maybe two years in and it was
like
a great upstart story it was like 20
employees all under the age of 25 doing
this cool disruptive social media you
know marketing at the time and uh this
is you know 2014 2015 and then you know
going acquired by this bigger thing
those guys had an e-commerce business
and so naturally they're like oh great
this marketing agency is a good business
to have it'll help our businesses plus
it brings in you know Revenue alone from
its service business
um and I think where he went so I think
the the simple explanation is
yeah his business got acquired
um
the overall business did a bunch of
Revenue
his agency did not uh but you know he
was a key player in that overall group I
think he was co-ceo of the group of the
group the group was you know one of four
or five divisions so he was kind of like
a division head at uh of uh of a larger
company okay great
where I think he went wrong is there's
like a clip of him on Dragon's Den and
the other guy's like do you even know
anything about business and he goes know
anything about business I built a 300
million dollar company by the age of 28.
um and that's like the clip that the guy
you know some people on Twitter
circulating being like ah okay I didn't
you're full of [__] dude you didn't
build a 300 million dollar business
there was a 300 million dollar business
that acquired your small agency
to that I say
they are correct he did
get yeah I mean to me that's like a very
maybe it's just relatable because I've
been in those situations where I kind of
like
I feel insecure in a moment and I can
imagine being a young guy on TV and then
the other investor says what do you know
about business I could see your
insecurity flaring up in a moment there
and try to say try to Puff your chest
out and say the biggest thing you can
even though it's not technically true
it'd be like when we got acquired by
twitch it's like you know I and then I
ran a division at twitch it'd be like me
saying I ran you know I built around a
five billion dollar company right that
would not be true that would just be
like you know
um puffing my chest out in a way that's
misleading so I think at the ER I was a
builder on a three billion dollar
company you're you're a builder right I
was a part of a company that that was I
joined a company 13 years after it was
founded and uh you know I was early
but but I've I've felt that for example
I've I I feel silly about this now which
is that when we got acquired
the deal was said the deal was I know uh
was no like no PR like no no disclosure
of the terms
um but somehow it got leaked to
TechCrunch and I think a couple others
that we we got Acquired and
um they put a price in there of 25
million
and the price was not 25 billion it was
less than that
um but the answer's got to be no comment
but I was like I could have corrected it
so I could have gone and said
no it wasn't that I didn't even have to
say what it was I could have just in
retrospect I could have just said
it's lower than that but I can't
disclose instead I just said hey I can't
say anything about it I'm not I'm not
allowed to say anything and twitch also
said that I'm not allowed to say
anything it's so just sat out there and
a bunch of people were like wow great
exit 25 million and I'm like yeah that
would have been a great exit uh it's
still good but less good than that so
that's not the accurate number and
that's still just what sits out there
today is that people think that that's
what the number was
and it kind of benefited me I remember
in some ways and every time it benefited
me I felt guilty and just like it's also
a weak move to like
uh take a representation that makes
something you did seem greater than it
actually was
um so I didn't like that and but I can
under I can relate to this moment where
you're like the ego part of you or the
insecure part of you wants to feel like
something is he wants to say no I did a
great thing uh so you know I I
understand where he's coming from in
that point of view but I don't really
see what the controversy is besides that
I think it's just like is the dude more
famous
than what he did with his agency yeah
probably
but he's famous because he's amazing at
creating content and he's a great like
he's he's a great brand Builder he's
built his own brand uh how old is he
he's only 28 maybe yeah he's like this
yeah mid mid to late 20s something like
that so I mean I'd say you're doing all
right dude yeah he's he's pulled up he's
pulled it off I think I think the haters
have a point
yeah he did over represent he did over
represent in some ways yes that's true
uh every time he says I built a company
worth hundreds of millions of dollars
it's not really true
um
he's a very hateable guy not because I
dislike him I actually like his content
but I think he's hateable because he's
young he's good looking he's successful
he's pretty I don't know cocky but like
confident I mean you know it's easy to
hate people uh so yeah he's he's in some
regards a very hateable guy yeah when
you have everything that people want uh
that's what I know okay you've got money
Fame looks charisma you know whatever
body what else is there you know I'm not
sure I'm not sure he's really missing
anything so so yeah there's there's a
natural visceral reaction some people
have to that which is like either a it
can't be all good there's got to be
something wrong and I'm gonna find it or
B
[__] that guy I'm tired of seeing him on
my Instagram feed
what um what's this Financial Freedom
thing that you wanted to talk about let
me do let me do two Okay so
I want to uh
I want to do this story about this uh
this woman I met who I think has a
really cool cool business so
um a couple podcast episodes ago I said
hey I got this idea for a d2c business
it would be best run I think by a woman
who's like got it because it's a it's a
product for women
um and it uses my my joke which is like
uh I don't know how to pitch it exactly
so it's like a normal thing but
beautifully done I just imagine like you
know pens but just beautifully done
right like and it's true like that's
part of the shtick of this product this
is just like
it's well packaged and well made uh
beautifully done and so anyways I got a
bunch of inbound and I I joked about it
I was like oh to our four female
listeners if you're out there this could
be an idea for you
um and a bunch of people replied maybe
20 30 40 people said hey what's the idea
I wanted to hear about it uh here's my
background and one woman had a really
interesting background so her name I
think is what is it Sarah Michelle
something like that
um she started this business I'll pull
up her name yeah Sarah Michelle so she
she built this business called NP
reviews I'm guessing you've never heard
of this but here's why it's interesting
she basically built a course prep
business and sold it for more than 10
million dollars in two years
and I just think that's kind of a badass
move to pull off you don't hear of a lot
of course based businesses that sell it
all uh let alone sell for eight figures
in two years and what she did was
basically she built like cat like Kaplan
like the test prep thing for nurse
practitioners so and so um it's called
NBA reviews as a nurse practitioner
reviews past your nurse practitioner
exam the first time stop stressing and
start studying Smarter with our proven
exam review courses exactly so she
basically says yo you're in school to
become a nurse practitioner you have a
the the big test is coming up it's like
your version of MCAT or else that's if
you're a lawyer
um the nurse practitioners have that
same thing and it's like
great
take you know work with us and you'll
pass they have a 99 pass rate amongst
their students so they're like you know
don't wear it she's like don't worry I
was in your shoes wow I was stressed
about this and I pass and if I could
pass you could pass I've helped so many
people pass since then
um and what she does is it's basically a
funnel where she's got ads about this
and content about about you know this
exam or becoming a nurse practitioner
which leads you to this landing page
which says don't stress we got you 99
pass rate
um if we help you pass your upcoming
exam and then she funnels you to a
Facebook group so basically it's like
join the group of 25 000 other people
who have passed this exam and um you
join the Facebook group and you buy at
one of the courses so you can buy this
like 300 a month one 130 a month one 100
a month one whichever one you want
um that fits like whichever test you're
planning to take
built this thing up sold it to a company
called blueprint that basically is
rolling up these test prep things and um
I just thought that's an amazing exit
and I'm uh I'm super impressed and
here's why it's awesome if you go to the
bottom right it says powered by kajabi
that's a hundred dollar a month software
that yeah anyone can get the president
of kajabi listens he uh oh I know yeah
he dm'd me as well so it's a 100 a month
software and they have like a 30-day
trial so you can even like not pay and
just like get your get get courses like
spinning up and then making some money
so the website it it's fine looking but
it's not like you could make this
without a designer uh the copy is pretty
solid very clear problem
copy is very good like yeah I haven't
read it all but it's just decent look at
the like just the headline just a quick
Copy thing so put this up on the screen
on YouTube so go to mpreviews.com just
want to point this out so the headline
says pass your nurse practitioner's exam
the first time
so what is it you know leading with a
the outcome or the benefit you want
versus talking about yourself she could
have said
we are a test prep you know a six-week
test prep program get with uh live
online classes and a community blah blah
that's how most people pitch their
products they talk about themselves she
talked about the outcome then the second
thing stop stressing and stop start
studying Smarter with our proven AAA
ancc and ANP exam review courses okay
great stop stressing so it's the
emotional like the emotional state
you're in and tells you you know the
emotion the better emotional state
you're going to be in and then after
that she basically is like I did it you
could do it I've helped these 500 people
do it here's some testimonials from them
here's some pictures of their faces and
they're holding up their like
certificate that says I passed and
they're like thank you Sarah you helped
me pass my exam and then she's like
there's there's like a Founder lips I've
been in your shoes feeling anxiety as
you prepare for your nurse practitioner
boards you're not alone the stakes are
high and these tests aren't easy you
need to review course to help you master
this I get it because I've been there I
remember how I felt studying for this
that's why after passing both of my
exams I decided to create a review thing
to help others too uh since these launch
I've helped thousands of people with 98
pass rate uh here's you know how it
works blah blah blah join our Facebook
group and check it out
um just a really well done really simple
product really simple idea and I think
this by the way this idea could be done
with any like trade that has
certification so personal trainers get
certified for their like Health uh you
know stuff and they take this these
programs that uh they have to get
certifications for whether you're uh you
know dental hygienist a speech therapist
there's ongoing architect it could be
anything ongoing professional education
and anything that there's a you know a a
finishing school for so like med school
nurse nursing school whatever
cosmetology or whatever it is being the
test prep for that it obviously she's
not the biggest one like Kaplan makes a
few billion dollars they offer they
offer prep for mcats and offer prep for
nursing nursing school but you just
carve out your Niche and you're the more
trusted face you're the more human brand
and it's beautifully done
[Music]
where's the worst have you heard of
HubSpot see most trms are
adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better
dude this is why I hate that question
when people ask me if you could start
over again with nothing what would you
do and I say I would do the same thing
and they go does that still work and I
would always say of course it does now
we have an example milk Road did the
exact same thing within the last 12
months and I have another friend named
Ben tassel do you know Ben uh he um
yeah he had a oh that's what we're doing
we're calling it milk road now it's the
milk Road of of like the hustle sort of
like the milk Road for General business
it just happened to proceed about five
years yeah
Andre the Giant was just the same par of
wrestling uh yeah that's what we're
gonna do now I like that he's a big buff
guy he's pretty much the same part of
wrestling
um triggered
uh well anyway like I say I would do the
exact same thing and now you're an
example you did the exact same thing and
then
um uh now there's Ben and Ben goes well
I'm just following I I heard he goes I
heard in the Pod that Sean said he just
copied you so I'm gonna copy Sean
copying you and you know what it's
working it's working he's got this AI
newsletter and it's working and there's
a handful of businesses there's a bunch
of businesses where it's basically the
same thing all the time but a little bit
different and maybe not even better just
a little bit different or in a
particular Niche this course business
this is another one of those where it's
just the same thing her website is I
think it's only like eight or nine or
ten Pages she's got the webinar she's
got like the different offerings the
Facebook group it's the same thing that
you can do in any case and in some cases
this could be a home run I bet you know
like
um I sold a little bit early but morning
Brew is doing I think they said 70
million in Revenue industry dive sold
for 500 million dollars those are all
home runs
um same with the course business I think
there's a world where you can do the
exact same thing it could be quite huge
although 10 million dollars is is
awesome so that's why I think that
whenever people ask that question it's
stupid or I hate it because you're just
looking for an easy answer and you're
looking for permission to not to do
something because you want me to say
it's outdated or doesn't work anymore
and my answer to that is no no it works
it works don't ask permission just do it
right yeah there's a there's a better
version of that question uh that
question is sort of like the question
when somebody asked Elon Musk they're
like and Elon you're a great inspiration
to many entrepreneurs out there what
words of advice do you have to somebody
uh to encourage them to start a business
and he goes if you need words of
encouragement to start a business don't
do it
that's how I feel about like if you're
really clueless about what ideas should
I do
um
first of all this whole podcast has
hundreds of ideas of and examples of
ideas you could do
um don't overthink it you could just do
any of those secondly you should have a
running list of irritations and problems
that you experience in your professional
and personal life that you're like God
if somebody made a way that made this
better or made this easier or made this
faster or made this cheaper I would buy
it that's a great source of startup
inspiration if you're just like I don't
know maybe Sam will tell me how to be a
successful person that's not what
successful people do
now having said all that
I'm doing it again
I have a little example of this okay so
I've talked on here about my uh my
personal trainer and my personal trainer
uh is uh my buddy J A you you've met him
before awesome guy has uh become a great
friend and has delivered a ton of value
in my life
um
as you know I basically was not working
out and was like you know on this steady
climb of like yo I'm gonna gain 15
pounds a year for what was your what was
your what was your Peak weight 250 220
not too probably at 230 was was like
230.
um and not like oh I'm bulking it wasn't
muscle mass let's put it that way and uh
and so anyways I get in touch with Jay
and I'm like hey I want to make a change
uh he's like awesome how often do you
work it out right now I'm like zero
times a month and he's like cool okay
let's let's start there and so he came
over and took me from like zero to now
working out five days a week eating
better you know seeing a bunch of you
know great gains and results getting
stronger fitter healthier more mobile uh
all those things I'm playing basketball
again my life has gotten a lot better
and so I'm like dude you help me with
this one area I really wanted help in in
my life uh how can I return the favor
okay I know I'm paying you but but how
can I help you even be on that and so
he's basically always wanted to have his
own successful business and he's like
he's like I see what you do
um I think that's awesome I want kind of
the same I'm thinking about e-commerce
or this or that
he goes I want that I want that and I go
all right dude I got it for you I have a
idea that I think will work that I think
will make uh it'll be successful which
is great because that's what we want we
don't want to fail the second thing is
it will lead to a lifestyle that I think
you rejoice not a ton of like grunt work
that doesn't take a ton of capital up
front and so I'm basically check this
out I'm gonna create I'm helping him
create a milk Road for personal trainers
and so basically it's going to be a
newsletter that goes out every morning
to other like it could be Fitness
enthusiasts but I think start starting
Market is just other trainers so train
the trainers is the thing I keep saying
and because I'm like dude
you are awesome with workouts you're
awesome with mindset stuff you find all
these interesting like I don't know
links to like cool like oh Andrew
huberman said this thing about the
supplement check this out you know blah
blah
um and I was like dude I feel like if
you just kind of published your daily
you know your daily what's going on your
day today as a trainer
um that would just be an awesome email
to receive if I was another trainer so
we created this format and we created
this brand and what I'm going to do is
I'm gonna help you get the URL
uh yeah so the URL there's no sign up
yet but I just got the domain uh it's
it's so the email is called The Daily
pump and so it's mydailypump.com is
gonna be the email so go go register for
this because I want feedback on it um
but I'm gonna build this whole thing in
public so milk Road I didn't build in
public I was like
oh this is a good idea I'm gonna Sprint
on this and basically one year built the
thing up until the largest crypto
newsletter in the world uh and sold it
and so you know had a had an awesome
outcome there and now that I did that I
know how I would do this in like 10
other spaces I don't really want to go
do that because it feels like I'd be
just doing I'd be on the hamster wheel
just playing the same level of the video
game even though it's probably smart I
have the the knowledge now of how to do
it it'd be too boring I don't want to do
it but this has a different like meaning
right if I could help him build up this
business I think that will be you know
like just helping my friend out with
something that I know would really uh be
helpful to be impactful to them and so
uh so that's what I want to do and I'm
going to share how we build this thing
up you know sort of step by step and my
it's been a really interesting process
because he's not from the startup or
business world and so a lot of times at
the beginning I was like oh yeah we
should do this
and he's like yeah yeah dope
um and then he wouldn't do it and I'm
like I got frustrated and I this happens
to me with a bunch of people who I'm
like dude you I meet somebody they're
like oh I wanna improve my situation I'm
like oh yeah you just got to do this or
I'd I'd back you if you could find
something I'll bring the capital you do
the work
and they're like yeah yeah yeah and then
three weeks later I don't hear from them
and I used to think oh it's because
they're lazy and I actually realized
it's not because they're lazy they're
not lazy people in fact usually the
person I'm trying to help they're
working 10 times harder than me at their
day job right one guy was a plumber and
uh you know it's like okay this guy's
doing much harder work it's not that
he's lazy it's that they're afraid and
they're confused so they're afraid to
fail and they're afraid to look dumb if
they do the wrong thing or saying the
wrong thing to me and they're also just
confused they don't know where to start
they just never started something like
this from scratch and for me I knew we
spent now 15 years doing this it's very
easy to think oh dude I just spin up a
landing page I would set this up on
beehive and then I would go over here
and I would do this and then I would I
would not focus on that other stuff and
I wouldn't care about advertisers till I
get to 20 000 subscribers and like I
would scrape this email list I would do
this ad and I would and they're like
dude I don't I've never run a Facebook
ad I've never done a landing page never
done any of this stuff I don't want to
talk about that stuff publicly I I kind
of regret it a little bit because like
you had this at milk Road I didn't I had
it a little bit as well where like
people in South America or other
countries were just like copying they
would like translate it and then just
send the email like 30 minutes later and
in one regard it's flattering but
another I'm like
um and sometimes it's harmful but other
times it just pisses me off
um most of the time it just pisses me
off it's not harmful but I don't I've
changed once we got audiences I was like
I don't want to talk about this stuff
and so I get nervous about that now I
don't think you have like whether this
thing succeeds or not it doesn't impact
you other than you want to help your
friend so I want to help you I think if
I talk about it publicly it's going to
keep me invested in it it's Gonna Keep
Me engaged because I'm gonna have to
like keep reporting the story and I also
think it's easier for me to justify the
time because this takes time for me to
help and I already had a pretty busy
plate but if I could say well you know
what I'm able to use this for stories as
content that that then then I don't have
to separately make other content so
that's my selfish justification I also
think uh if somebody was going to copy
this blueprint I wouldn't do it in
personal trainers that's only because he
is a personal trainer there's 30 other
niches where this would work better than
for personal trainers
um and I think that because it's
specific to him and it actually fits his
it's authentic and if it's his his
actual like where he is a master like in
the same way I'm like dude I don't get
it why don't you just blah blah blah
what I realized was he probably looks at
me and says the same thing he's like
dude I told you to increase your protein
intake and just eat these macros you'll
get the body you want six months
but here I am at your house and there's
a Chick-fil-A wrapper what's going on
here right like that's the equivalent
right like or he'd be like oh you should
wake up and do this morning cardio thing
fast fasted cardio it'll only take you
10 minutes sounds so easy
sure enough I he shows up I got some
excuse as to why I didn't do it
I'm like oh I just forgot that like a
beginner is always going to go through
these stages and I just got to stay
patient with him the way he's been
patient with me now I do those things
when he says them much better than I did
at the beginning you gotta get this page
up though you got to get this page up by
tomorrow or I'm gonna get it up before
this uh before this thing is done but
the cool thing that I've been doing by
the way is I've been posting I've been
texting him one thing every day I'm like
yo you gotta just do uh I'm like the way
you get like you give me a workout of
the day it's like sit down for as I go
to the gym for an hour and you're gonna
do this workout and I just got to listen
to you follow your blueprint and it's
gonna get the result I want because
you've done this you've mastered this
this you're a black belt in this I was
like I'm gonna do the same thing on the
business side I'm not gonna hope you get
hope you figure it out I'm not gonna
leave it to you to figure it out I'm
gonna give you one thing a day to do
it'll probably take you about an hour
I'm gonna give you your daily workout
each day and um and so that's how we're
doing it one day one little text message
at a time and I'm like his business
trainer the way he's my personal trainer
so it's been kind of interesting to see
how that's worked that's been pretty
effective to be honest I'm eager to see
if you regret this or not he'll pull it
off it's going to be at least mildly
successful because he's got a massive
head start because we're going to be
talking about it but I told him I was
like dude I'm not going to give up on
you I was like if I was like you would
have you could have given up on me and
been like dude this guy's not this guy
you paid him still yeah I pay him but
like you know so there's obviously a
little difference there but like there's
a difference between you show up and do
the job or you go the extra mile he goes
way the extra mile with me so like you
know
uh my kids are raging out he'll be
holding one of my kids so I can get the
workout in while he's training me or
like he'll come in on an off day and
just make the gym better just just a
surprise and be like look I want your
environment to be dope because you're
going to just get that extra five to ten
percent juice and join your environment
and you know a trainer doesn't have to
do all that they don't have to come and
rearrange your gym and and help you with
your kids or show up you know stay for
two hours extra because whatever you
know that sort of stuff
so I've got this friend named Nick Gray
do you know who Nick Ray is he's the uh
Party Guy so Nick Gray is my good friend
yeah he started a thing called Museum
hack where he took he had another
company that like made parts for private
planes or something like that that he
sold and then he started a thing called
Museum hack which was Private Tours and
museums he sold that now he's got a new
thing called the two-hour cocktail party
it's a book on cocktail parties and how
to host the perfect cocktail party it's
honestly quite good I use his techniques
he's doing this new thing that he just
showed me where whenever he goes to a
bar or a restaurant or a museum or
anything he takes a picture of the food
or the the front of the building and he
reviews it but can you see the go to the
MDB link I I have in there look at what
he does so he posts a review of the
place but he puts his book in the
picture and he's been and he's been
testing this
and over the past couple months his
photos there's like analytics on it
they have two million views on his
pictures and this guy Nick he's crazy so
he just tweeted out this thing he goes
I'm gonna host a conference for all my
ex-girlfriends he's got a lot of
ex-girlfriends because he dates a lot
and he's very Charming so girls love him
but he's really nice and so he stays
friends with all of his ex-girlfriends
one time this guy for his 40th birthday
party he rented out a a water park and
there was like 30 of us and I swear to
God I'm not exaggerating four of the
guests were his ex-girlfriends and they
were all hanging out together and he's
like I'm gonna so this guy's crazy but
look at this you can you see the link to
his Google is so funny this is the
funniest growth hack I've seen in a long
time so he has a Blog do you think this
is effective I would never do something
like this he's got this blog post coming
out tomorrow or the next day and it's I
think if you just Google Nick Gray
g-r-a-y you'll see the blog post I I
don't know the name of his website it's
probably just nickray.com
uh and he's gonna like reveal the
results but he was showing me this I was
like Nick why I was just out to eat with
them the other day and he was and he had
his book with them he pulled it out of
his bag and he was taking a picture I go
what are you doing he goes check this
out and he showed me his Google reviews
he goes they have analytics on this that
my vid my uh photos in the last couple
months I've gotten to 1.8 million views
1.9 million views is this hilarious or
what that's so funny that's this is such
a funny and it reminds me of somebody
the story is better than the actual
growth hack so somebody said this about
um Pinterest too they go yeah Pinterest
man they were such Grinders I remember
they used to go into the Apple Stores
and change all the default
um default homepages to pinterest.com on
the Macs that are sitting on the table
yeah and who knows if that works I'm
like dude this guy's spending hours
driving to Apple Stores to try to get
like five Impressions on his website and
think that somebody's gonna be like huh
you know I went there for an iPhone but
you know what I really want to do what
was that website I saw on the demo
computer I'm gonna go sign up and make
an account and become a daily active
user like that doesn't happen but the
story The Hustle story is makes it worth
it and I've done I've done several of
those where the hustles makes it sound
like you were going to the nth degree
even though it made zero sense to do so
he has reviews of everything there's one
of Panda Express of Lululemon of
Charlie's Subs Vans the store any store
that he goes to he's taking this really
good picture of like the front like
there's a Great American Cookies it
looks like it's just like an Annie aunt
in the mall he takes a picture of the
front and just has his book in his hand
there's this guy on Yelp that Sarah and
I follow because he has he like tests
all the good food places in New York and
San Francisco and he had a newborn when
he started doing it and all the pictures
of his newborn eating the food and then
it was like you see the baby get like
one year old two-year-old three or four
I start like getting to know this kid
and we're always like look that guy's
been there and it's actually an
interesting hack that I think could
actually I don't know if it this one
will work but there's like these weird
personalities that I've seen on Yelp and
on Google reviews where I start to get
to know them and I trust the reviews and
it's actually a really fascinating
platform to hack and I wanted to bring
that up because I've never really seen
uh like insights like this and I think
it's incredibly fascinating yeah that's
super cool do you know what I'm doing
right after the top of the hour yeah you
have uh can you talk you want to
announce it what you're doing yeah yeah
yeah so how did you do this by the way
how did you pull this off all right so
we have this guy named Michael Harris
nicknamed Hario
I don't know I'm gonna interview him and
find out his story so I don't want to
like reveal his whole story because I
don't know the whole thing but basically
he's one of the co-founders of Death Row
Records and when I sometimes Sarah and I
my wife we volunteer in prisons and we
work with this thing called The Last
Mile I've told you about the last mile
my friend Chris he's a tech guy he
started it it basically helps teach
inmates how to do Tech stuff so
hopefully they can get a job once they
let out well a lot of those people are
like convicted murderers it's wild and
through that I met Michael and he
basically went to prison for 30 years at
the a in his 20s and before that he made
up to a million dollars a day selling
crack and cocaine I think and helped
discover Denzel Washington and sponsored
or funded uh Broadway plays and things
like that and parlayed that into music
and thus created Death Row Records which
shook night and he has all these stories
about Snoop Dre Tupac so we're going to
talk to him uh uh and figure out a story
are you a little bit intimidated to have
this conversation incredibly because I
don't know you're not like the big a big
pop culture guy but like basically like
there's you know he's a girl with me
he's I'm pop culture dude you didn't
know who Dolly part was but basically
like I there's a lot of like I read a
book about Eazy-E and easy and Dre and
death row had a beef and I don't know
like where that stands and like if I can
say who I'm a fan of and who I'm not a
fan of so I'm a little nervous because
this guy it's not like our friends or
our enemies on Twitter where we're just
gonna argue of course this guy will
never do anything bad but like
you know like that's it's a little bit
more real he's more capable for sure
don't make the mistake of um
don't make the mistake of like
referencing Somebody by first name if
you don't know them they'll be like yeah
I was reading about ease and uh they say
ease yeah easy but I don't know I'm just
trying to seem cool here it's like what
people yeah so they say they're coming
to visit the Bay Area and they go hey
I'm gonna be in San Fran this week and I
just have to tell them I say hey man
listen just as a friend nobody says San
Fran here so you're just outing yourself
as a tourist as soon as you say that
that's how I feel so I feel I want to be
respectful
um and I but I also want to like let
them know that like you know I've
listened to all this music I've read a
lot of books about it but purely from an
academic standpoint
so like that's yeah so it feels like a
little funky but like I was talking to
him the other day because the reason I
got in touch with them is he wants to
like launch some podcasts or he's just
brainstorming and he asked to talk to me
and I said yeah and he starts talking
and I'm like hey you realize that like
when you're talking to me about this
drug trade and things like that like you
talk about delegation and empowering
your co-workers and things like that
like right this is business stuff do you
want to come on the Pod and so I thought
it'd be cool yeah we've had people
who've made you know originally this
podcast called my first million because
it was
let's interview people who've made a
million bucks in many different ways so
I interviewed you know a business person
then I interviewed a poker player and
then somebody who made it through
selling um you know weighted blankets
online and somebody who made it doing
you know deodorant somebody made it
doing 100 got junk and like a whole
bunch of different things but now we
have somebody who who did it in uh in
some other some new ways selling crack
cocaine uh record label and who knows
what else that's I think it's gonna be
amazing I'm joking around just because I
know if I was in your position I would
feel a little squirmy uh going into it
like just like how do I not say
something stupid like I know this could
be great this is when things are are
tough It's when you know it could be
great
but you also know it could easily go not
great if you don't build rapport or you
don't really know how to guide the
conversation properly because it's not
your standard interview right like if we
brought somebody on
who built a SAS company to you know 20
million dollars would be like cool I
know the same I know 20 questions to ask
you that are all safe you're going to
give me 20 answers that are all safe and
um I know exactly how the conversation
is going to go and it really can't go
anywhere that's out of my comfort zone
in terms of a question or a or a topic
to talk about whereas this one's going
to be you know the ZIP code is out of
your comfort zone so you're not gonna I
I know how I would feel going into that
interview that's why I I wanted you to I
wanted you to come
um because I thought it'd be fun since
you are you're you're even a few more
zip codes away than I am are you sure
are you sure you can't make it you
should uh yeah yeah exactly Death Row
Records name's a bit crude don't you
think
do you ever think of something softer
like milk Road for example no
um yeah unfortunately I got another
thing scheduled at that time but um um
all right that's the Pod by the way the
gentleman's agreement is working by the
way I went to a party with a bunch of 23
year olds sounds a lot worse than it is
a friend turned 23 he asked me to go
Jeffrey's party on an island yeah yeah
yeah it was that like the Lolita like
Taco uh taco place no uh
he I had so many people come up to me
and said hey by the way I honored the
gentleman's agreement that's because the
show we have this thing called the
gentleman's agreement we make this
content for free and um but it's not
actually free to listen in exchange you
got to go subscribe to our YouTube and
it's working we're getting like 800 to a
thousand new YouTube subscribers a day
so
yeah this basically is 3x the number of
daily subscribers we were getting on our
YouTube channel
everyone told us to do this the whole
time and we're like you're an idiot
they'll no one follows that yeah we also
we we kind of yeah we say it a lot now
but for like two years we never told
anybody to do anything so we're just
kind of we're due yeah we're due
[Music]